welcome to the Macmillan report I'm
Marilyn Wilkes your host and our guest
is david cameron professor of political
science at yale and the director of the
program in european union studies at the
Macmillan Center professor Cameron
teaches courses on European politics and
the European Union over the past several
weeks the European Union has been caught
up in a crisis
over the size of the budget deficit in
Greece there has been speculation that
Greece might default on its debt and may
need a bailout by other member states of
the EU or even the IMF there's even been
speculation that Greece might be forced
to give up the euro and leave the
eurozone some think the crisis could
spread to other countries in southern
Europe Spain Portugal Italy that like
Greece participate in the eurozone but
have large budget deficits and high
levels of debt meanwhile as we recently
saw in Greece there have been huge
demonstrations and strikes protesting
the government's efforts to reduce their
deficits professor Cameron joins us
today to discuss the current eurozone
crisis why it has arisen and what's
likely to happen in the near future and
the longer term
welcome professor Cameron thanks Marilyn
why did this crisis arise
well this crisis arose for several
reasons a year ago
Greece projected a deficit of 5% of its
GDP there was an election in October
last October and a new government came
into office and it reported that
Greece's deficit figures were not
correct and in fact the deficit would be
rather than 5 percent about 13 percent
of GDP and they said that the previous
government had falsified the figures
that added a strong sense of anxiety
among those who hold the very large
amount of debt that Greece has in the
world some 300 billion euros so that was
that's a real problem that the deficit
is so high in a country that has such a
high debt and the credibility issues so
those taken together really created a
problem Greece has to go into the
markets repeatedly this year to raise
money about 55 billion euros and
investors are somewhat anxious and
reluctant and concerned about whether
Greece can pay back its debt and whether
it might instead default or the EU might
have to intervene but those are some of
the background features that have come
into play in the last month or so
okay let's talk a little bit more about
the deficit why is it such an important
issue for Greece and the other countries
that participate in the eurozone
okay the eurozone is the set of member
states of the European Union that have
locked their exchange rates agreed to
replace their national currencies with
the euro and have turned over monetary
policy to the European Central Bank in
Frankfurt and one of the conditions of
membership in the euro zone and one of
the continuing conditions for member
states that are in the euro zone is that
they keep their deficit under 3% of GDP
now that's a completely arbitrary number
it was concocted about 20 years ago for
reasons that are somewhat mysterious but
nevertheless the all the member states
have been committed to that deficits
over 3% of GDP
are regarded as excessive so we have
Greece as a country which everyone
thought had a deficit of 5% it now turns
out it's about 13%
so it has to bring its deficit down at a
time when it's experiencing very low
growth in fact this year the projections
are negative growth its unemployment
rate is already over 10 percent but
that's that's the essence of the of the
problem that they have a deficit that
has to be brought to reduce basically
from 13% to 3% okay so the new Greek
government has said that it would reduce
the deficit this year by 4 percentage
points of GDP and bring it down to 3
percent of GDP by 2013 do you think that
is realistic it's going to be
exceptionally difficult exceptionally
difficult both fiscally and politically
it's difficult fiscally because what
that means is they have to raise taxes
on all kinds of commodities alcohol
fuels cigarettes income tremendous
amount of tax evasion in the country
that they have to deal with they will
probably have to raise their value-added
tax the v80 tax in addition they have to
cut spending and that means cutting
spending on pensions on health care on
public employment cutting wages cutting
the number of workers it's going to be
very difficult to do that it would be a
heroic step if they could actually
reduce their deficit from 13 to 3% over
three years I don't think anyone really
thinks they will do it but they clearly
have to head in that direction and
that's really the the challenge for them
now what makes this politically
difficult is that the new government is
headed by the PASOK party Papandreou is
the leader of the PASOK party the
Panhellenic Socialist Party it's a Left
Party it's connected with public sector
and private sector unions
and much of the reduction in the deficit
in terms of reducing spending increasing
taxes is going to hit its core
constituency workers public sector
workers so forth so it's very difficult
for them to sell this politically and we
saw yesterday a national general strike
of public and private sector workers
there was a public sector general strike
two weeks ago and it will be very
difficult for the government to sell
this and that's the real challenge so
it's a double challenge both a fiscal
challenge and a and a political
challenge oK you've talked about the
deficit let's talk a little bit now
about the debt and how they're connected
okay well Greece is unusual among the 16
eurozone member states and that it is
the only one that has a double-digit
budget deficit and a triple digit debt
to GDP ratio it has over one well over
100 percent of debt relative to GDP it
that's about 300 billion it has to go
into the markets as I said for about 55
billion euros this year and it's already
gone in once in late January for 5
billion the debt was oversubscribed but
it required them to pay a very high
interest rate they are planning to go
into the markets again very shortly for
another 5 billion probably but they will
also pay a substantial risk premium on
that debt as well the real challenge
will come though in April and May when
they have to go into the markets for 20
to 25 billion to redeem some of the debt
that is coming due so they are faced
with a real challenge and the real test
is going to be what happens when they go
back into the markets
and and will there be people who will by
the death now the EU the leaders of the
EU met recently to I guess determine
whether or not they are going to give
some assistance to Greece and apparently
they have not decided to do so can you
shed some light on that yeah there was a
meeting two weeks ago of the European
leaders the heads of state and
government there called the European
Council they met in Brussels two weeks
ago to talk about a number of topics but
this of course took primacy on their
agenda and the real question was what
would the EU do in this situation and
would it provide any assistance to
Greece now there are a number of member
states that felt that given the way this
crisis arose because of falsified data
and fiscal irresponsibility it would be
wrong for the for the EU to reward that
kind of conduct and what they really
decided to do more than anything else I
think is hold the Greek government's
feet to the fire it had already pledged
in January to the European Commission
that it would in fact reduce its deficit
by 4 percent of GDP this year and 10
percentage points of GDP over the 3
years and Greece said we don't need
assistance right now
and they were right they didn't need
assistance at that moment but the EU
didn't want to offer a signal and say
well fine don't worry we'll take care of
your debt we'll bail you out there was
considerable opposition some of the non
members of the eurozone that is
countries in the EU that are still not
in the euro zone such as Britain and
Sweden said if Greece has a problem it
should just go to the IMF in the same
way that hungry went to the IMF in the
fall of 2008 Latvia went to the IMF last
year so forth Germany who certainly
wasn't
in favor of a bailout or financial
assistance so what the EU leaders said
was they asked the finance ministers to
recommend additional measures that
Greece has to take and to create a team
of members of the Commission aided by
the European Central Bank and the IMF to
go to Athens and study the books look at
the books pour over the books look at
every aspect of fiscal policy and come
back and report to the finance ministers
in March about whether additional
measures have to be taken I think
everyone in the EU thinks that the
package of measures proposed by the
Greek government won't get them down
from 13 to 9 percent of GDP deficit this
year and they are going to need
additional measures but that's something
we won't know for sure until March when
this team reports to the finance
ministers on March 16th okay do you
think there's a chance that Greece will
be forced to leave the eurozone and and
forgo the euro no I don't think so I
think Greece will stay in the eurozone
and keep the euro if they left the euro
it would be exceptionally difficult for
them we've never had a country leave the
eurozone there's really no exit clause
you would have to bring out the old
currency again reintroduce it take the
euros out of circulation the drachma
would be very substantially depreciated
relative to what its implicit exchange
rate value is now and the debt
denominated in Euros would increase very
substantially for Greeks all those who
owe euro denominated debt so there would
be a large number of
alts bankruptcies in Greece it would be
probably a full-scale economic
catastrophe moreover there is a very
substantial amount of Greek debt that's
held by French banks about 75 billion
and German banks about 50 billion and so
they certainly don't have an interest in
having the situation deteriorate so I
think they won't be bailed out they
won't break out in that sense they might
be assisted and I think that's much more
likely that the European Union will
perhaps on a voluntary basis on a
state-by-state voluntary basis decide
that there might be a good reason to
step in and help Greece perhaps by
buying some of their bonds when they go
into the market for this twenty to
twenty five billion or having their
banks buy some of the bonds and stand
behind them with loan guarantees or
other guarantees I think that's what
will happen it'll be something in other
words between going to the IMF and
giving up the euro Wow what about the
speculation about the other countries in
southern Europe and this crisis
affecting them as well what do you think
will happen there well that's a that's
been a big concern of the Europeans of
the EU and and a question that's looming
over this Greece is an important state
of course but it's a relatively small
state but it's not the only state that
has a problem Portugal has a deficit of
about 9% of GDP
Spain has a deficit of about 12% of GDP
they both have deficits that have to be
brought down it's very difficult to do
that obviously especially when we're in
a situation of serious economic or you
might say the aftermath
the economic crisis of last year Spain
for example has an unemployment rate of
roughly 20 percent right now it's very
difficult politically for governments
and it turns out Spain and Portugal both
have party governments controlled by
left parties very difficult for for any
government but especially one with
that's controlled by the left to
implement austerity programs at a time
of where the countries really haven't
begun to recover that's politically very
hard to sell so they're facing this
problem as well now the difference with
Spain and and Portugal is they don't
have nearly as much debt as as Greece
relative to GDP their debt to GDP ratios
are in the area of 60 to 80 percent
which is high but it's not nearly in the
triple digit range the Greece is in and
they also don't have the credibility
problem that Greece has you know one one
person said recently there are lies damn
lies and Greek statistics Spain and
Portugal don't really have that problem
at least as far as we know so there may
be some speculative attacks on on on
Portuguese and Spanish bonds which might
mean that they have to pay a high risk
premium or an increasing risk premium
but I don't think they're going to face
the same problem that Greece has Greece
is really the problem and that's the
problem that has to be solved from the
point of view of the EU a difficult
problem to solve okay if we step back
and look at the big picture there's what
happens suggest there are more
fundamental and deep-seated problems in
the EU s plan to create a single central
bank I think so I think if I think if
you asked that of an economist an
economist would say what this crisis
illustrates is that the eurozone is not
an optimum
currency area the countries are not
sufficiently convergent in terms of
their economic structures the underlying
structures for them to really have a
single currency and that's correct and
it certainly will be correct when the
other member states of the EU come into
the eurozone this is a political
construct it's not an optimal currency
area it wasn't designed to be one I
think the more important problems though
looking forward are that the crisis
suggests two serious problems in in the
EU one involves a problem of
competitiveness and the other is the
problem of coordination and ultimately
economic government competitiveness
meaning that the countries of southern
Europe that are in the eurozone Greece
Portugal Spain and Italy to a large
degree really aren't able to compete as
well as they should be able to compete
with the other member states in the
eurozone those countries the the
southern countries have experienced the
trade deficit every single year since
they locked the currencies in 1999 they
have not been able to sell as much in
terms of exports and they've been buying
a lot more imports from the other member
states of the EU there are some deep
problems in their economic structures
and the EU members when they created EMU
glibly assumed that if the countries met
certain statistical requirements they
would have a high degree of convert
sustainable convergence that clearly
hasn't happened there is a competitive
in this problem that really reflects an
underlying structural problem the real
question is how do you deal with that
competitive in this issue in a system in
which there is no economic government
and one of the interesting things that
has happened in this crisis is
more and more people are beginning to
look at this old idea that came up in
the mid-90s when Europe began to move
toward EMU of an economic government the
French proposed this idea in a way to to
offset the control by the European
Central Bank over monetary policy they
felt the finance ministers should be
able to control fiscal policy and
coordinate fiscal policy well they have
a euro group that is the finance
ministers of the member states that
participate in the eurozone but the Euro
group has no powers it meets for dinner
the night before the finance ministers
meet every month but other than that it
has no real power and as we saw last
year in the economic crisis the EU was
really not very able to coordinate its
economic response to the crisis its
response was I think would be generous
to say was feeble last year now many
people have looked at this crisis and
said given the fact that the EU is now
sending a team that includes IMF
advisors and ECB advisers to Greece to
look at its books look go over fiscal
policy make recommendations for other
additional measures that will have to be
adopted probably in order to get some
assistance from the other member states
that in a sense the EU is taking one
small step toward economic government
it's not clear exactly what economic
government would mean but it would
probably mean basically exercising
collective authority over the fiscal
policies of the Member States and in
that sense this crisis may move you're a
small small step toward economic
government but I should say we just had
completion of the negotiation and
approval of the Lisbon Treaty which took
effect in the
December first last year and no one in
Europe after the long process of trying
to revise the institutions that ended up
in the failed constitutional treaty and
then the Lisbon Treaty no one in Europe
can imagine writing another treaty and
going through that long decade-long
process in any time in the near future
so we're likely not really to get to
economic government but it is at least a
vision that is back it's back on the
agenda as a possibility very good well
it'll be interesting to see how things
unfold it will be thanks very much for
being here with us today you're welcome
for more information about professor
Cameron and his work please visit our
website at Yale edu backslash Macmillan
report be sure to join us again for
another episode of the Macmillan report
made possible through funding from the
Whitney and Betty Macmillan Centre for
International and area studies at games